primero que todo Cuáles son esos
hallazgos generales que ustedes tuvieron
en este estudio
bueno nosotros en primer lugar lo que
hicimos fue hacer un estudio aleatorio y
no fuimos primeramente a dar casos por
casos de tortura sino que sabíamos nos
temíamos por todas las conversaciones
que teníamos con los familiares y vamos
a encontrar que la mayoría eran
torturados y efectivamente así fue
respondieron aleatoriamente digamos un
buen número de familiares tenemos 250
declaraciones y con todo eso armamos 181
casos de presos políticos en los últimos
12 meses de los 1.277 presos políticos
que ha tenido Cuba esos 12 meses
181 casos y todos son torturados todos
pero además el 80% de ellos tiene cinco
tipos de torturas sobre sus espaldas o
más niños el el más el que más tipos de
torturas soportado 17 años un menor Los
menores
tienen unos patrones de tortura y los
jovencitos de 21 para abajo que salieron
a manifestarse el
11 de julio del 2021 tiene unos patrones
de tortura horribles horribles
ahora han tenido alguna respuesta por
parte del gobierno cubano al respecto
no pero vamos a ver yo no espero una
respuesta de un gobierno que viene
haciendo estos 64 años y que ahora se lo
hemos levantado completamente hemos
levantado la alfombra y se ve toda la
porquería no espero ninguna respuesta
salvo ataques porque lógicamente las
personas que hacen esto las personas que
digamos detienen
persiguen Bueno no sé todo todo en todo
hay un camino pero cuando ya se llega la
tortura es decir lo tienes preso lo
tienes indefenso lo tienes esposado y le
haces desmayarse del dolor a una mujer
durante tres ocasiones ya eso no es de
un gobernante eso es un enfermo mental y
como enfermos como eran los Videla o
como pinochet de enfermos lógicamente
tenemos que liberar este mundo y no es
para dialogar es para demostrar todas
las barbaridades que se están haciendo y
que la gente se dé cuenta de lo que está
pasando en cubano señor larrondo ustedes
toman como Punto de partida el 11 de
julio de 2021 cuando comenzaron estas
masivas manifestaciones anti
gubernamentales se dispararon las
torturas Desde esa fecha
Bueno lo que se han hecho es más
numerosas porque claro hemos pasado
tener un entorno de 140 presos políticos
en Cuba una disidencia pues muy mermada
cualquier digamos que no tenían forma de
crecer orgánicamente Por lo cual cuando
surge el 11 de Julio se pasa a tener mil
y pico presos políticos y lógicamente
las torturas que infringían a 140 se las
infringen a 1000 en este caso ahora
mismo a 1050 como hay ahora Pero además
con una característica estas personas no
son políticos no no ni si algunos tienen
familias revolucionarias entre comillas
es decir eran personas que salieron a la
calle a decir queremos un poquito de
esto queremos libertad queremos Patria y
vida queremos Reconciliación o sea
salieron con Ánimo bonito no eran
políticos y claro ahora están abrumados
les ha pasado una apisonadora 10 años de
condena por sedición imagínate no
entonces
jovencitos que están sufriendo además
las torturas al panorama es terrible el
panorama es muy duro muy triste